[Music]
Nancy follows me on Twitter at Dave
Ramsey is it okay to accept a job that
pays less but has excellent employee
benefits no because you are placing
value on those benefits that is absurd
and you're making your decision using
your own critical thought okay you're
assuming that the only way to get
excellent benefits and the only way to
cover the issues that the benefits cover
is to take less pay why don't we go with
another option make more money with
excellent benefits
let's see everybody has to dumb this
down you have to assume the only way I
can be happy to make less money the only
way I could get securities make less
money the only way I could get benefits
is make less money why do you always
have to put make less money at the end
of these sentences why can't you go I
can make more money and be happy I can
make more money and get benefits let's
see you got to look at it that way to
start with I can live my passion and
make more money but it's amazing that
people think that there's some kind of a
trade-off here that's a false it's a
false it's a false logic which is
actually an oxymoron but um it's just
it's bad critical thinking skills so no
no no no it's not okay okay okay just
for that reason it's not okay hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]